nathan apodaca's viral ocean spray
moment put
fleetwood max dreams back on the
billboard charts and gave the song
their best streaming week to date but i
gotta tell you that wasn't the only
music
that saved 2020. joining me now is
melissa johnson and mtv's doma t pongo
to talk about the collabs
the returns and the surprise drops that
we got this year what's up you guys
let's talk about the major collabs we
saw
in 2020 because there were some big ones
which collab do you think made the
biggest
impact though this year dome team let's
start with you oh man
you gotta start off with whop i mean
meg the stallion i mean that had
politicians tweeting
wow that i never thought that i would
see politicians talking about what a
well you know the rest
i mean this was a big collaboration
between two of the hottest female
artists in the game i mean
there was no bigger song than wife the
only other one might be
the collab between megan the stallion
and beyonce
other than the savage remix being meg's
first number one
hit in dominating tick tock the song
success
literally made a tangible impact on
people all of the proceeds went to the
bread of life a houston-based charity
helping out relief when it comes to
covid and houston
i know covet relief that was amazing
definitely necessary but
i think the shock waves that watt made
is the moment that we're going to be
talking about for years to come
but it also got people dancing i'm i
mean [ __ ] and savagery mix i mean
okay i got rugby trying to do the whop
dance like
i put the leg trying to do that man
the bruise on my hip it's still healing
but you know more than anything yes
we couldn't ignore it everyone was
talking about it but they just made you
feel good
if i could danny there was one collab
that made a big impact on the hip-hop
community and me personally
uh which was alfredo the album
collaboration between rapper freddie
gibbs
and producer the alchemist the alchemist
legendary hip-hop producer
and you you know it didn't come out with
any tick tocks didn't have any dance
videos but that album this year
is nominated for best bath album at the
grammys and you usually don't see
an album that's this lyrical that this
that's this cerebral
with samples most of the songs don't
even have choruses
yet this collaboration project between
this producer and this mc
uh is being recognized by the grammys
and i think that just speaks volume to
how
dope that project was so it ain't
whopping and they savage but it was a
really impactful project collab
i love it don't t your your music taste
just jumped out
and that's like that's why you're here
listen you know besides these monster
collabs
you know 2020 also gave us some major
returns
we saw people like lady gaga come back
into the dance pop space with chromatica
brandy the chicks among people who put
out albums this year that we haven't
heard from them in a minute
um how do we think this year affected
these comebacks
you know i think what really helped the
comebacks are the versus battles
we've seen some really innovative things
happen throughout this quarantine
and brandy doing that versus battle with
monica got us so hyped
for b7 and when b7 finally dropped it
did not disappoint
brandy's lpb7 was her first album in
eight years
and as a fan who still listens to her
1998 album
never say never consistently up until
this day
this was a huge bright spot for me
i mean she started working on this album
about three years ago
and it's an album that focuses on self
self-worth mental health
and her own spiritual transformation so
i think the
divine timing of it all was great
because she didn't i mean she didn't
expect 2020 to be what it was
but when it came out this year i think
it resonated with a lot of people who
are also working on self-worth mental
health and spiritual
transformations in their own lives we
missed that voice didn't we
i feel like she definitely feel to fill
the void but it's interesting because
like brandy's you know the message
behind her record i feel like the same
could be applied with lady gaga you know
she put out her first studio album in
four years
she went and did the whole stars born
won an oscar thing and then came back
to her roots really with this like club
dance
pop record that while it was
while i was filled with bops and stuff
that you should be blasting and dancing
to i mean the the lyrical content of it
it was all from you know a place of her
focusing on her mental health and
turning
sadness into you know her super power
and so i was happy to see gaga return to
form this year too
2020 because it was so stressful you
know we look for
reasons and ways to escape and lady gaga
taking us to the world of chromatica
really spoke to some of that escapism
that's that
surreal world that she takes us in every
time she releases it
and she did that once again this year
when she came back with that well since
we're talking about the divine timing of
it
i just wanted to mention the chicks
really quick they gave us their first
album in 14 years it was titled
gaslighter
and of course i mean i know you all know
this gaslighting means when someone
tries to manipulate you
into doubting reality and i feel like
we're going to talk about the divine
timing of everything
that sums up pretty much what we've
experienced over the last four years
and especially in 2020 so they hit it
definitely on the head and it was just
good for them to be back they're so
influential
in their powerhouses in this industry
and malicia they came back with a new
name
you know i don't know what it is you
know yeah they removed dixie from their
name because
2020 came this bigger larger
understanding of words how we use them
we rethought
how we capitalize the b in black as it
denotes racial ethnicity
and the dixie chicks and the word the
pain that comes with the
dixie time period right that time frame
you started to see this awakening
happening in music and the chicks also
use that
as fuel for their their rebranding with
this uh with this new album so
divine time and indeed we also can't
talk about those newsmakers without
talking about a couple really big
surprise drops this year from some huge
artists two in particular
there was taylor swift's folklore and
also bad bunny dropped his third
album this year el ultimo del mundo
i mean i know i miss live music do you
guys feel like these releases kind of
softened the blow
of no concerts this year
it absolutely did man and bad bunny
he really made my heart drop calling his
album the final world tour
you know he really wanted everybody to
think that that would be it for him
i loved his album previous to this was
one of my favorites
and then when this came i'm like wait a
minute what is he saying he allowed
people on twitter to go on and on about
it to
kind of you know guess that whether or
not this would be his final album before
he finally came out and said yo if this
was my final album what would it look
like and
because tours have transformed you know
you have an
album all of these artists are using
different forms of creativity to figure
out
how they can still keep fans engaged
still get some of that live energy out
there
without hitting the stage in person i
think bad bunny is one of the best to do
that
i talked to bad bunny about this record
and you're right he was building up this
anticipation right here and also
reflecting on the times he was like not
even lady gaga can go out on tour right
now so that's why i'm calling it the
last tour of the world but
i also uh from chatting with him feel
like he was alluding to the fact that he
will be taking a little bit of a break
you know he has been uh really pounding
pavement
and has had such a breakthrough globally
as this like crossover artist
i i mean the fact that that this last
record literally hit the top of the
billboard hot 200 it's the first
spanish only language album to do that
he knows he's put in the work and he
told me he's looking forward to a break
so i feel like we got to enjoy the new
music he gave us this year again three
albums because
it might be a minute before we see him
again and of course we have to mention
taylor swift
and folklore i think that definitely
softened the blow for her fans who are
looking forward to
her lover fest world tour but she had to
cancel it of course due to covet 19
along with a lot of
other artists but lucky for her fans who
just always
seem to just be in a good space taylor
is just always gifting them with
something
this they always try a lot exactly but
this break allowed her time to create an
entire new album
you know if it wasn't for 2020 i'm not
sure if we would have received folklore
plus she released a disney plus film
document
documenting the making of this project
so
i feel like fans her fans specifically
got a lot more than they probably
expected from taylor this year
and can we also add that both taylor
swift and bad bunny
they cannot fit in just one box anymore
i mean they crossed genre and doma t we
saw a lot of that this year
uh what did you think of all the
crossovers you know as far as like the
genre bending goes
oh we saw a lot of albums that like i
don't even know pretty soon if genre is
going to be a thing
there are so many different versions of
multiple art forms and one artist
that does that really well guys may or
may not have heard of him pretty niche
out of the uk
tom mitch who has an album called what
kind of music and what kind of music
is literally about like what kind of
music is this you know you're partnering
with yousef diaz who is a drummer
and actually uh freddie gibbs is on his
album as well talked about him earlier
uh but the project goes from jazz to hip
hop
to neo soul to r b and back to jazz
again and it's sort of this journey this
experimental journey and you see
multiple artists do that you've seen
that
a lot of world artists like that bunny
who we just talked about
and whiz kid who dropped multiple albums
in 2020 he just dropped made in lagos
this year as
well afrobeats has become a part of the
the world music lexicon with rappers
featuring on afro-beats records
so many different collaborations pretty
soon i think it's gonna be
harder and harder for us to know what
genre different artists around yeah also
i feel like this year everyone
collaborated with doja cat dojo cat got
on a track with ariana grande
with the weeknd bibi rexa chloe and
hallie
uh something tells me that not only does
she have a breakthrough year
this is going to be someone everyone's
going to be clamoring to collab with
kind of like when
i feel like megan the stallion too yeah
when she popped off last year you know a
lot of people were like oh we got to get
meg on a track and stuff like that so
yeah
you were talking about missing live
performances dosia cat
made it much easier to go with that life
because she has been killing these
courses
she has hasn't she everything and
they're all
different we only have a couple minutes
left but i'm gonna put you both on the
spot
um i need to know what is the album or
the artist
that saved 2020 for you donati we'll
start with you
that album for me was my turn by little
baby
that album should have been nominated a
rap
album of the year there was not a rapper
alive who didn't want a little baby
feature because every song he jumped on
made its way to the billboard charts and
he has a good mix
of uh club records to
songs like emotionally scarred and
something to prove
that bigger picture that was a political
a political statement
i got power now i got to say something
yes
and this year you also tied with prince
and paul mccartney with 47
entries on the billboard hot 100 and 12
tracks off of my turn charted
so i mean this dude was breaking records
yes and i just i just let it out man
that
it turned me up and allows me to get
introspective at the exact same time it
was a perfect project
denny my pick if i had to choose i was
here for the comebacks this year
so i'm going to go with my girl jasmine
sullivan
goodness look this is soulful she's
angel
her voice is just angelic she dropped a
single in august titled lost ones
and recently she dropped pick up your
feelings which is my jam
she's going to release her new album
hotels in
january i believe january 8th of 2021
so this is her first album in six years
which is something i'm definitely
looking forward to
next year and she just makes good music
well you guys both know
i'm the pop guy and i feel like the
artist that really
tried to come and save who tried to come
to save pop music in 2020
was dua lipa because she really brought
disco back with future nostalgia
but also her she was one of the first
artists to decide to
drop their new record during the
pandemic i feel like it was at the very
beginning of quarantine and so i know
she has gone on the record to say that
she
pushed back the release they debated
whether they should drop it at all
but she went for it and i just feel like
it came at the right time
a time where as you explained doma t we
kind of needed that escapism
and there was nothing more you know
nostalgic or futuristic
than future nostalgia and i mean it
really got me dancing and i just
appreciated it because it was kind of
again there were so many things to look
forward to and one of them was you know
her follow-up to her debut
and she delivered so for me i feel like
i'll be dua but also i just want to
quickly honor
give an honorable mention to a future
superstar
rina sawayama i don't know if you guys
listened to her debut record
it was elton john's favorite record of
2020 so that's saying something
i have yeah just give her a quick shout
out because i thought her record this
year was also amazing so well go reena
go right here go read it and god
that i got some taste outside of top 42
okay
i was like respect to do it but look out
for rina sawayama for sure
anyways this was way too much fun doma
team alicia thank you guys so much for
joining me
uh here's to a new year okay full of new
music
hopefully some live shows hopefully some
concerts but uh malicia before i let you
go
you you both mentioned actually earlier
versus and brandi's return
uh she came back and uh it wasn't just
the new album that we got hamel
that's right denny as domentie mentioned
earlier 2020 was
the year of versus battles and that
meant a trip back in time to brandy
monica and the boy is mine which was
another one of my jams
we have that story up for you next